welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber an Iowa Man released
early from prison is lack is locked back
up again he's accused of kidnapping a
little girl and killing her the
prosecution gave its opening statement
on Thursday in the case of Henry Dinkins
and we want to make the connection
between the defendant and the alleged
victim clear here so Dinkins is not her
father rather he's the father of her
half-brother breesia Terrell and her
brother were staying with Dinkins and
his girlfriend overnight in Davenport
Iowa in 2020. at some point during the
night it's believed that Dinkins took
breesia from the apartment and killed
her her disappearance prompted a massive
search but her remains weren't found
until nearly a year after she was
reported missing fishermen spotted her
body in a pond about 25 miles away from
Davenport in March of 2021. at the time
Dinkins was locked up on an unrelated
charge see it turns out he's a sex
offender who had been released early
from prison but was required to register
and police say he didn't do that so they
arrested him then when briation's
remains were found they charged him with
kidnapping and murder the prosecutor
laid out what dinkin's girlfriend says
happened that very night
it happens to fall back the curtain
to the window and looks out and little
griasia is standing by a maroon Chevy
Impala on the passenger side of the
vehicle Mr Dinkins returns to the
apartment
he comes up
he's very very frazzled
Miss Culberson wants to know what's
going on he said there's issues I'll
talk with you about it later
where's Croatia there's no creation
and then she goes down to the maroon
Chevy Impala
riasia is not in the car
when the three gentlemen went to go
fishing they were walking down that seek
incline having Parker pickup trucks up
on the road
and because we're talking about March
22nd
there's no vegetation
one of the gentlemen looks over to what
would be his right as he's walking down
looks to the north essentially and he
sees a human soul
he points it out
to his two friends they go over and
check and sure enough it is a human
skull
because riasia Terrell and her having
been missing was so highly publicized
the gentleman will testify that at some
point they made the connection is this
free agent tomorrow
okay let's break this down I'm joined
right now by my co-host defense attorney
Brian buckmeyer Brian good to see you I
want to start with the sex offender part
is that going to be playing a role in
this trial because on one hand it's not
connected but on the other hand he
shouldn't have been around minors and
was supposed to register and didn't is
it going to play a role in the case at
all I go back and forth with that
because I I do think especially when the
prosecutioner was talking about maybe a
consciousness of guilt when he comes
back to the home without the daughter
and he just kind of freaks out as the
way they put it but we're talking about
a sexual conviction from the 1990 when
he was 17. now he's 51 so there's two
issues one are the crimes truly
connected the the sexual assault or the
registration and this two it's over 30
years ago how are you going to use what
he did then to try to show some sort of
Innocence or guilt here now but again
again this is a crime against a minor
should the jury not know about that is
it a sexual crime well that's a good
point that's a good point I guess the
question is how important is it for the
prosecution to put that in there you
heard the opening statement do you think
that they have enough in this set case
without presenting anything about his
past
I think they've got it and I think
that's where where the judge will push
back and they would say why do you need
this if you've got the circumstantial
evidence of him leaving with the
daughter him coming back without her
what does the registration have to do
with any of this and I think that's
where the prosecution will struggle the
other thing too is once you say he's a
sex offender and he should have
registered he's not supposed to be
around minors my feelings of the defense
is fear and the judge's fear is the jury
closes their ears and they say forget
about it and that's where you get into
the land of two prejudicial and not
probative enough so you talked about
that you think they have enough what do
you think they have enough just the idea
of that he was the last one with her
because her body wasn't found like the
next day it was found you know about a
year later what's the strongest evidence
you think against him is not necessarily
one piece of evidence that is strong
this is I think a really uh good test
case for Reasonable Doubt because
they're not they don't have direct
evidence but all the evidence around it
doesn't have a reasonable explanation
for him not killing her and I think
that's the defense's real struggle here
find a reasonable explanation for him
not being the one and maybe they have a
case but right now I don't see it it's
just disturbing case to say the least
and um you know it's interesting we
talked about the sex offender because we
were having a conversation this morning
and some of the people we were talking
to said if I was on the jury and I knew
that about him they would probably
convict him on that alone
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody so we're continuing our
coverage of the start of Henry Dinkins
kidnapping and murder trial the case is
a little bit unique because the
defendant chose to have a bench trial
instead of a jury trial so Dinkins is
accused of taking a 10 year old girl the
daughter of the mother of one of his
children while she was sleeping over at
his apartment briasia Terrell was last
seen alive in Davenport Iowa in July
2020 and her skeletal remains were found
the next march by some fishermen Dinkins
was a sex offender who was in police
custody when brazier's body was found
for failing to register Dinkins chose to
have a bench trial now that means that a
judge is going to decide his guilt or
innocence and there's no jury when the
prosecution wrapped up its opening
statement on Thursday the defense
decided to hold off on their opening a
little bit longer
and that's all for the state
thank you Miss Cunningham Mr Freeze says
the defense is going to present an
opening statement you honor the defenses
all right thank you very much that'll
conclude the proceedings this morning
I'm surprised by this Brian why he chose
to have a judge over a jury usually my
understanding is you choose a bench
trial when there's like a complicated
issue of law you think maybe the judge
will be better you know suited to handle
that than a jury why do that here so
there are two reasons why a person would
have a bench trial rather than jury
trial and you have the right to a jury
so oftentimes you can choose the first
one which I don't think it is is when
you get that wink and the nod from the
judge and I've had that before when the
job when you're making arguments of
defense attorney Justice doesn't work
and the Judd says don't worry about it
so and when you get that you know the
judge is going to take care of because
they understand and then probably on
your side when they're not saying it but
that's not the issue here I think when
you have such a gruesome case and
there's a potential where you might have
the fact that your clients and
registered sex offender come out you
really want to focus not on the
emotional and the disgusting aspects of
it you want to focus on a very key legal
issue that you're hoping the judge will
focus on and ignore the rest as opposed
to a jury who would take it all in it's
a good point I mean I also I should tell
you this we know that this was moved
right it's moved from Scott County to
Lynn County and then back once it was a
bench trial how does that affect
anything so it moves from Scott County
because of the high publicity and I
think that's where they were like I
don't want to do a jury trial right and
they went to Lynn County and they said
hey even if we go to Linn County maybe
they pulled the jury maybe they kind of
uh looked around and did focus groups
and said we're still not good here and
so I think they might have done a little
bit of of forum shopping or judge
shopping and said if we go back and have
a bench route we don't have to worry
about a jury pool in Scott or Lynn
County we can go back to the judge we
had before who's heard all these
horrible issues for months and months on
end it might not be a reactant to it as
if someone would hurt it for the first
time and I think that's a bit of the
strategy here and speaking about the
defensive strategy the fact that they
chose to reserve an opening statement my
the history that I've seen that is
mostly let's see what the prosecution's
case is right though it's not we don't
have to jump the gun on what we want to
say yeah a defense attorney doesn't have
to give an opening statement and they
can do like they did here in reserve
until afterwards it also gives you kind
of like a two bites of the apple of a
summation because you get to give your
opening after the prosecution's case and
then you get a closing afterwards and so
you can kind of like you said see what
they've got poke holes in your opening
after their case and then do it again
after maybe present a case or in your
closing and I have to imagine that's
more beneficial in front of a judge
who's seen that happen before than a
jury who might be like wasn't the
defense supposed to go right here and
they might you know make something of it
that's maybe also a consideration as
well